[Music]
how many of you would consider
yourselves to be emotionally intelligent
people oh definitely
he's emotionally genius oh I think she
would never call me a genius about
anything else that's super nice I think
you're pretty emotionally challenging
well thank you I'm emotionally me
[ __ ] help you are you progressed so
much you really I think I got better but
cuz I gave him emotional calculus like
and my emotions are like and he was like
he sold like he sold it like Google
hunting its advanced rocketry yeah oh we
should be thanking Nicky damn it yeah
yeah thank you yeah I can't get my
credit will be we'll have a fight right
and we're not only talking for not right
now and then she comes and hugs me and I
found out that normal people if they
feel the hug and that's what they wanted
that's what they want to begin with they
just hug back and then they make good
and then everything's cool for me you
know how to hug bad because I think I'm
like so Asperger's that everything has
to be like one at a time don't have a
saying I'm like so we're in a fight and
then I'm like why are you hugging me if
you're mad and this is like you just
ruined the [ __ ] moment and then she
goes away it sounds I mean like you
might have something I'm like away so
cuz I didn't understand what the hell is
going on I also didn't know how severe
your
it was I took the test and the test the
the online test it's ad-supported bro
Steve always holds me - to this day well
right now yeah it's like after we come
out of quarantine I do want to see a
psychologist to see if I have some yeah
we get raided on this day so it seems
like anything over twenty nine you have
Asperger's and I have I got 32 or 33
what Asperger's like were you too
literal and you don't emotion you don't
get social cues got it like let's say if
I go this is extreme version it's now
it's not this bad but it's pretty close
we're like let's say I go to a movies
with the Platonic
Fran that's also a female I'm single
she's single and we're just watching
movies and like let's say she ends up
falling like this it puts her hand on me
I'm like then the most guys with all guy
I get from this gesture what she wants
yeah so well I will continue and then
progress in this relationship for me and
be like oh why did you put your hand on
my knee you know so the subtleties of
life you are not you know you don't know
the subtleties a lot I don't know or
here's a fun example Zeo is like hey
maybe you could like like smack my ass
during sex
and so barkos is that what you said to
do that well you see I don't think it's
maybe you're on the spectrum no I just
think his parents are also not very
emotional they're also very logical oh
that could be Asperger's to be genetic
or could be modeled behavior I think
that's what it is
I think it's modeled behavior but in a
hate when equals joy but I do want to be
able to recognize that the girl wanted
that you know girls would want this and
then you but there's a lot of things
that I call out that I mean do did make
the first move did you she did star I'll
give you the cliff notes we've known
each other for three years we hate each
other and then we somehow developed
feelings for each other pretty quickly
and then I'm like damn it's pretty
obvious that I like him and we've been
flirting you text okay what's gonna
happen is I'm gonna make a move and I'm
like I can't wait anymore and I just
made them what was the mood what was it
did I kiss you oh I started just kissing
him all up she's much bigger guy he's
like this is close to the mouth maybe
this will be positive why did you kiss
me here probably kissed like four times
before I got to the corner of the mouth
Wow
you know what is waiting for you to make
the actual move or you're the
Bicentennial man stretching exercises
something's wrong with me like always
like cool this is one of the most
friendliest kisses I've ever ever see
like should give me a mom kiss I don't
get it what yeah yeah yeah years ago how
old were you guys when you met 23 25 I
forgot I don't know well if I'm your age
- 12 okay i'm sorry i'm out i literally
win in my I've had enough okay I can't
believe a lot of his own houses kids
joke I'm not cool cuz I couldn't say all
of us because of earlier Burnham Bart
said that earlier I know they had houses
all a Bart said that earlier that's all
johner anyway let's get into this okay
was just so interesting it is I don't
know what that was but I always learned
so much when I'm here your mother and
one day I'm like mmm
but then is it correct you have to go I
have to check if there are the right
thing when you all right so what I have
here are twelve traits that emotionally
intelligent people have so so it's like
domains and core competencies so we have
self-awareness self-management social
awareness relationship management so
this this article is more geared for
like leaders like bosses and stuff
they're talking about this but oh okay
under self-awareness is emotional
self-awareness self-management under
that is emotional self-control
adaptability achievement orientation and
positive outlook under social awareness
there's empathy organizational awareness
under relationship management
there's influence coach and mentor
conflict management teamwork and
inspirational leadership and it's a lot
this was due this was due the next
morning and they forgot they had the
project due and their doctor spending 25
years writing books and rosters but only
one night but that it was due the next
night - she procrastinate and he yeah
sounds like someone no procrastinate oh
yeah
so this article really goes in-depth
into each one there's a lot so there's
one that stood out what was one that's
not weird this is so as emotional
self-awareness that's just one circle
whole circle has some sparkle what else
is in this category just open they're
like I gotta put something down here
three hours why I put the circle so big
you can't turn a project you with eleven
circles number
just gotta put a motion to move on I'll
come back and fit won't even notice crap
there's not enough time
let's put 25 years on there though no
don't forget about it it got
progressively better but something got
to the Blue Square they got five circles
ready their rocket rolling by I don't
know let me see which one self awareness
self awareness is the most I think okay
so under that one it says you ant
understand your own strengths and
limitations you operate from competence
and know when to rely on someone else on
the team you also have clarity on your
values and sets of purpose which allows
you to be more decisive when setting a
course of action so in order for you to
develop the skills it says every moment
is an opportunity to practice
self-awareness one of the biggest keys
is to acknowledge your weaknesses yes if
you if you're struggling with something
at work for example be honest about the
skills you need to work on in order to
succeed be conscious of the situations
and events in your life to during times
of frustration pinpoint the roots and
cause of your frustration think about
any signals that accompany how you feel
in that moment and that is being
self-aware so that's great yeah so
actually this is acknowledging them not
thinking you can do everything yeah
people respect you way more especially
if you're in the leadership saying we
don't know things it's great - but do
you need to be able to like like handle
the other people's like greed their
their emotions does that don't know how
it goes into like social awareness got
it and then like organizational
awareness it's like oh that's makes you
like emotional intelligence like IQ and
EQ yes a lot of leaders have good IQ but
low EQ then I eat you is more important
I choose more no oh no no they say the
opposite in terms of a lot of leaders
great leaders tend to have high
emotional losses how you don't define
great leaders cuz like for example Steve
Jobs not good not a high EQ but a high
IQ so like you know was he a good leader
I don't know but he was a good CEO
people don't want to get gay and he just
kind of so but wasn't the other people
around him who had to do that part and
he was just like innovative also the
softener was wasps yeah yes like for
number two self-management is the
ability to keep disruptive emotions and
impulses under control which is a
powerful skill for leaders especially
during a crisis because people will look
to them for reassurance and if their
leader is calm they can be too hmm
yeah so emotional self control is what
we just said adaptability it shows this
shows up as agility in the face of
change and uncertainty so you're able to
find new ways of dealing with fast
working challenges and can balance
multiple demands at once and an
achievement orientation you strive to
meet or exceed a standard of excellence
positive outlook you end up always
seeing the good in people in situations
and in events and that is incredibly
valuable you should look for it at least
not necessarily see it but look for true
yeah yeah and just assume it benefit of
the doubt until they betray you betray
this revenge mode and where are people
betraying you didn't you crush their
soul maybe you think about why they
betrayed you oh no no no that's their
fault with you their problem unless they
unless they tell you what's wrong with
you then that's like their problem oh oh
no you're self-aware but if they're not
telling you what if they got probably
they're not telling you what the problem
is it's on that that's what happened me
in high school
[ __ ] this kid up emotionally
[Laughter]
I'm scared and I'm the scary one right
it was definitely Steve oh he deserved
it
[Music]
you